when you want to watch a movie or a TV
show you know what to do you tap your
fingers and within a few seconds you
were watching whatever you want it's
frictionless it's easy but in some
places it's not so easy I'm all denim or
television if I had a guy today on
national i'm officially there's one
source of permitted media in cuba and
it's the state okay solo segue but
cubans found a way to work around this
media blockade to distribute the latest
in global entertainment to the entire
country coordinated entirely by an
informal market of underground data
traffickers based both in havana and the
united states
it's the fruits of the internet without
any of the guts say no say yo holla say
de otra gente c'è face ELISA M behad hey
películas me otra persona embryos otra
la música es even go blonde on a mundo
para why once all the latest media from
around the world is gathered onto one
hard drive the top dealers in Havana
will prepare it for distribution this
extensive collection of digital media is
affectionately called impact at the
seminar the weekly package when I saw
metal on them all my face when I can
avoid the the otra persona que se la
caja is a persona yes si la escena de
una going oh no coupe you know gas again
always have a piece of se para pensar
que si
a quick look into the bucket day and you
start to realize how massive the system
must be together so much content in such
a short amount of time especially in a
country that has a 5% internet
penetration in an agonizingly slow
connection speed a la semana is a
trainer 3000 Vienna to the Vienna Moon
Luna
so for the Navi and he goes home in
talega say Rojo the negative
[Music]
obligación a quarter
- really
holla boyfriend got it
[Music]
so who's behind all this it's definitely
not one person but somewhere down the
chain there has to be a source of all
this information
someone coordinating the distribution I
found a couple of 20 year olds who make
their living hustling Havana's streets
participating in the thriving industry
of shadowy odd jobs between driving taxi
bikes without a license and giving
unofficial city tours to European
visitors these guys move at bucket day
between distributors from time to time
they led me behind the scenes in Havana
where I saw how the bucket day makes its
rounds every week the distribution
centers are usually in the back of cell
phone repair shops or DVD stores
Hardware flowing in and out of these
places doesn't attract unwanted
attention distributors were
understandably not King about appearing
on camera but they showed me their
operation and explained how clients come
to their shop with a weekly order of
digital content they told me that
American TV shows are in some of the
highest demand but some people show up
with an empty hard drive every week and
transfers the whole entire bucket
everything from iPhone apps to indie
documentaries after poking around I
finally worked my way up the chain to
discover who is coordinating this
massive enterprise they call him
Danny Paquette they and he agreed to
meet with me Danny
perfecto yeah oye could I see you
something right Danny was with a client
so I waited for an hour in his impromptu
lobby in order to expect any bucket they
to be like I figured he was some kind of
shady character like anyone you would
find behind some giant illegal
enterprise but I definitely didn't
expect this
he's a 26 year old who was wearing board
shorts and no shirt when I arrived he
looked a lot more like a lazy college
sophomore than a kingpin of a national
black market of pirated me Tina but
after five minutes of sitting in his
office with a client in the room I
quickly gained a respect for Danny and
the media machine that he's running as
Danny's 40-year old assistant helped
load the hard drive of a local
distributor I watched a live feed of the
popular Spanish Network Telemundo
digitizing on the screen Danny must have
a hidden satellite in a fake water tower
on his roof a fairly common Cuban
practice Danny's girlfriend wandered in
and began watching the Discovery Channel
documentary about a farmer who most died
on a tractor in Iowa so much for the
control of information by the Castros
dynamos
buddy hinten said responsibility' Oh God
assume the pilot Tohono me be a quick
there's one other competitor in Havana
for national pocket that consumers Danny
recently started sending one of his
runners on an airplane to the far
corners of the country in order to get a
leg up on the competition
you know I can't comment potential
there's no way of knowing exactly how
many pocketed consumers there are in
Cuba but of the hundreds of people I
talked to while there only two had never
heard of this and most were consumers
themselves
[Music]
so if there's one thing all of this
taught me it's that when people want
information they're gonna find a way to
get it
Cubans live on an island cut off from
the world's information for almost six
decades and they've come up with some
pretty innovative workarounds to their
situation as more technology slowly
spreads onto the island we can only
imagine what they'll think up next
[Music]